>>> IT HASN'T EXACTLY BEEN A
PEACHY WEAK FOR MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, WHO APPEARED ON A PUBLIC
ACCESS CALL-IN SHOW IN HER
DISTRICT A FEW NIGHTS AGO AND
GOT AN EARFUL.
>> THANK GOD FOR JOE BIDEN.
SHE IS AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
STATE OF GEORGIA.
>> WELL, WE ALL HAVE OUR
OPINIONS.
>> AMEN TO THAT.
AND I'VE GOT MINE.
>> ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU.
GREENE, WHO HELPED LEAD THE
RIGHT WING CHARGE TO OVERTURN
THE 2020 ELECTION RESULTS,
LEARNED PEOPLE BACK HOME HAVE
BEEN PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION TO
HER RIDICULOUS ANTICS.
ANOTHER LISTENER TOOK GREENE TO
THE WOOD SHED.
IT'S A LITTLE LONG BUT IT IS
WORTH IT.
>> YOU ALL REFUSE TO ACCEPT
BIDEN.
YOU REFUSE TO DO IT.
AND WE -- MAYBE WE DIDN'T LIKE
TRUMP, BUT HE WON.
AND SO THAT WAS IT.
YOU ALL ARE NOT -- YOU WILL NOT
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN
WON.
AND THAT IS THE WHOLE THING.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO ACCEPT IT.
YOU'RE GOING KEEP ON AND KEEP ON
AND JUST PECK, PECK, PECK.
YOU WON'T GET ANYTHING DONE IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO RESPECT THE
MAN AND REALIZE THAT HE'S THE
RESPECT, YOU'RE NOT EVER GOING
TO GET ANYTHING DONE.
YOU'VE GOT TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND YOU ARE NOT DOING IT.
YOU'RE NOT DOING IT.
AND NEITHER ARE THE OTHER
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE -- THEY'RE JUST GOING
WITH TRUMP.
NO, HE DIDN'T WIN IT.
HE DIDN'T WIN IT.
AND WASTED ALL THE MONEY IN
GEORGIA TO HAVE TO COUNT THE
VOTES THREE TIMES BECAUSE HE
SAID HE WON.
AND HE DIDN'T.
AND TO ME, IT WAS EVERYTHING IN
WASHINGTON WOULD BE -- WOULD
SETTLE DOWN IF EVERY -- IF THOSE
REPUBLICANS WOULD JUST SAY, WE
DIDN'T WIN.
IT'S LIKE, ALABAMA AND FLORIDA,
THE ALABAMA PEOPLE.
WE DIDN'T -- WE REALLY SHOULD
HAVE WON.
>> BLESS HER HEART.
THE LOOK ON THE CONGRESSWOMAN'S
FACE AS SHE LISTENED TO ALL OF
THAT -- IT'S A LITTLE EARLY FOR
VALENTINE'S DAY BUT I THINK I'M
IN LOVE WITH THAT NICE LADY ON
THE PHONE.
IN PART IT'S A SIGN OUR
DEMOCRACY STANDS A CHANCE AFTER
ALL.
AND IT'S A REMINDER WHEN YOU
PEDDLE THE WORST KIND OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, SOMETIMES
REALITY BITES YOU BACK.
GREENE HAS BECOME A RISING STAR
IN THE GOP, EVEN AFTER BLAMING
JEWISH OWNED SPACE LASERS FOR
CALIFORNIA WILD FIRES AND
COMPARING COVID RESTRICTIONS TO
THE HOLOCAUST.
>> THIS WOMAN IS MENTALLY ILL.
YOU KNOW, WE CAN LOOK BACK IN A
TIME IN HISTORY WHERE PEOPLE
WERE TOLD TO WEAR A GOLD STAR,
AND THEY WERE DEFINITELY TREATED
LIKE SECOND CLASS CITIZENS SO
MUCH SO THAT THEY WERE PUT IN
TRAINS AND TAKEN TO GAS CHAMBERS
IN NAZI GERMANY.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
ABUSE THAT NANCY PELOSI IS
TALKING ABOUT.
>> WE SHOULD POINT OUT GREENE
LATER APOLOGIZED.
BUT GREENE IS NOT ALONE ON THE
JANUARY 6th KARMA WATCH.
NORTH CAROLINA GOP HOUSE MEMBER
MADISON CAWTHORN IS FACING A
CHALLENGE FROM SOME OF HIS
CONSTITUENTS WHO FILED A LAWSUIT
ARGUING HE SHOULD BE BARRED FROM
CONGRESS FOR SPEAKING AT THE
STOP THE STEAL RALLY JUST BEFORE
THE ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
THOSE NORTH CAROLINA CITIZENS
NOTE THE SECTION IN THE
CONSTITUTION STATING NO PERSON
SHALL SERVE IN CONGRESS IF
THEY'VE ENGAGED IN AN
INSURRECTION.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WITH ALL THE
FRAUD THEY HAVE DONE IN THIS
ELECTION, THE REPUBLICANS HIDING
AND NOT FIGHTING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SILENCE YOUR
VOICE.
>> CAWTHORN, WHO RECENTLY WAS
CAUGHT ON CAMERA CLEANING HIS
GUN DURING A VIRTUAL
CONGRESSIONAL HEARING, HAS
REPEATEDLY TALKED UP THE
PROSPECT OF CIVIL WAR IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR MONTHS.
>> IF OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO BE RIGGED AND
CONTINUE TO BE STOLEN, THEN IT'S
GOING TO LEAD TO ONE PLACE, AND
IT'S BLOODSHED.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, AS MUCH AS
I AM WILLING TO DEFEND OUR
LIBERTY AT ALL COSTS, THERE IS
NOTHING THAT I DREAD DOING MORE
THAN HAVING TO PICK UP ARMS
AGAINST A FELLOW AMERICAN.
>> CAWTHORN IS BLOWING OFF THE
NOTION THAT HE COULD BE
DISQUALIFIED FROM CONGRESS.
>> THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
IMPEACHMENT OF PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
IT'S JUST THAT HE'S NOT IN
OFFICE RIGHT NOW, SO THEY'RE NOT
CAPABLE OF ACTUALLY BEING ABLE
TO DO IT.
SO, INSTEAD, THEY'RE GOING AFTER
HIS FIGHTERS.
THEY'RE GOING AFTER THE AMERICA
FIRST PATRIOTS.
>> THERE'S NOTHING PATRIOTIC
ABOUT HINTING AT CIVIL WAR.
THAT'S THE OPPOSITE OF
PATRIOTISM.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST GREENE AND
CAWTHORN WHO ARE FACING JANUARY
6th BLOWBACK THESE DAYS.
CONSIDER THE MOUNTING LEGAL
PROBLEMS FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND OTHER TRUMP
ALLIES.
THEY'RE PILING UP QUICKLY.
BUT THAT NICE LADY FROM GEORGIA
WHO WAS CALLING ON GREENE TO
WORK WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
PUT HER FINGER ON SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WERE SENT TO
GET THINGS DONE FOR HER
CONSTITUENTS.
YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED THAT SCARY
BRIDGE COLLAPSE IN PITTSBURGH
TODAY THE SAME DAY THE PRESIDENT
WAS TOUTING HIS INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ABLE TO BRING
A SMALL NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS ON
BOARD FOR HIS PROPOSALS TO FIX
THE NATION'S CRUMBLING ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE GOP
VOTED AGAINST IT.
THERE IS ANOTHER CATEGORY OF
REPUBLICAN WHEN IT COMES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE, THE KIND WHO
TAKES CREDIT FOR ALL OF THAT
MONEY COMING BACK TO THE STATES
DESPITE THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
IOWA GOP CONGRESSWOMAN ASHLEY
HENSEN TWEETED HOW SHE SECURED
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR A PROJECT IN HER STATE, EVEN
THOUGH SHE OPPOSED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
DEMOCRACY MAY BE IN PERIL, BUT
HYPOCRISY ISN'T.
PERHAPS SOME REPUBLICANS ARE
JUST CONFUSED, GIVEN WHAT'S
COMING OUT OF THE STATE TV
NETWORK FOR THE PARTY THESE
DAYS.
>> BACK IN JUNE OF 2021, HE
STARTED TALKING ABOUT HIS
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL.
THERE'S NOTHING BIPARTISAN ABOUT
IT.
IF IT WAS BIPARTISAN, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN PASSED BY NOW.
>> WOW.
AND THAT WASN'T EVEN TUCKER.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, THE BIDEN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL ONCE AGAIN
WAS BIPARTISAN.
AND ONCE AGAIN, IT DID PASS.
MAYBE THAT FOX ANCHOR WAS
THINKING ABOUT ALL THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEKS DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THAT NEVER
RESULTED IN ANYTHING.
HERE'S AN IDEA, MAYBE FOR ONCE,
JUST ONCE, GIVE BIPARTISANSHIP A
CHANCE.
GIVE DEMOCRACY A CHANCE.
I GUESS FOR SOME ON THE FAR
RIGHT, DEMOCRACY IS A BRIDGE TOO
FAR.
THE GOOD NEWS -- AND WHY DON'T
WE END THE WEEK ON SOME GOOD
NEWS -- IS THAT MAYBE WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THE LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE JANUARY 6th TUNNEL.
CITIZENS ARE FINDING A WAY TO
SEND